I want to tell you all about a piece
of American history
that is so secret,
that nobody has done
anything about it for 167 years,
until right now.
And the way that we're going to uncover
this vestigial organ of America past
is by asking this question:
Why?
As we all know --
(Laughter)
we are in the middle
of another presidential election,
hotly contested, as you can see.
(Laughter)
But what you may not know
is that American voter turnout
ranks near the bottom
of all countries in the entire world,
138th of 172 nations.
This is the world's most famous democracy.
So ...
Why do we vote on Tuesday?
Does anybody know?
And as a matter of fact,
Michigan and Arizona are voting today.
Here's the answer:
Absolutely no good reason whatsoever.
(Laughter)
I'm not joking.
You will not find the answer
in the Declaration of Independence,
nor will you find it in the Constitution.
It is just a stupid law from 1845.
(Laughter)
In 1845, Americans
traveled by horse and buggy.
As did I, evidently.
It took a day to get to the county seat
to vote, a day to get back,
and you couldn't travel on the Sabbath,
so, Tuesday it was.
I don't often travel by horse and buggy,
I would imagine most of you don't,
so when I found out about this,
I was fascinated.
I linked up with a group called,
what else -- "Why Tuesday?"
to go and ask our nation's
most prominent elected leaders
if they knew the answer to the question,
"Why do we vote on Tuesday?"
(Video) Rick Santorum: Anybody knows?
OK, I'm going to be stumped on this.
Anybody knows why we vote on Tuesdays?
Jacob Soboroff: Do you happen to know?
Ron Paul: On Tuesdays?
JS: The day after the first
Monday in November.
RP: I don't know how that originated.
JS: Do you know why we do vote on Tuesday?
Newt Gingrich: No.
Dick Lugar: No, I don't. (Laughter)
Dianne Feinstein: I don't.
Darrell Issa: No.
John Kerry: In truth, really,
I'm not sure why.
JS: OK, thanks very much.
(Laughter)
JS: These are people
that live for election day,
yet they don't know
why we vote on that very day.
(Laughter)
Chris Rock said,
"They don't want you to vote.
If they did, we wouldn't vote
on a Tuesday in November.
Have you ever thrown a party on a Tuesday?
(Laughter)
No, of course not. Nobody would show up."
Here's the cool part.
Because we asked this question,
"Why Tuesday?"
there is now this bill,
the Weekend Voting Act
in the Congress
of the United States of America.
It would move election day
from Tuesday to the weekend,
so that -- duh -- more people can vote.
(Applause)
It has only taken 167 years,
but finally, we are on the verge
of changing American history.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)
Thanks a lot.